one of the most debated topics in elden
ring lore
is
what makes an empirian
are they born or chosen
there's a lot of discussion about this
everywhere reddit youtube comment
sections discords etc so in this video
i'm going to show you the two arguments
of the conversation their general ideas
and where they got the information from
but do know that this video is not to
tell you which one is true or which one
is it you should believe in because
honestly no one truly knows and what you
want to believe is entirely up to you
i'm just here to show you the in-game
references being used so you can make
your own head canon about it and if you
want to know my opinion i think it's
both i'm trying to stay as neutral as
possible now i'm going to be playing the
entire scenes of the important npc
dialogue that associates with the two
theories so that nothing is cut out from
the context there will be timestamps
that you can use to skip
those dialogues if you've heard them
before and i'll do my best to explain
both sides of the topic as well as their
counter arguments
now before we go on with the arguments
let's first explain what an empirian is
though to be honest what we know is very
limited but what we do know is that
empirians have the capacity to become a
true god and be able to take over
america's place as either the vessel of
the elden ring or just a new god in the
lands between
the debate though is the criteria to
become an empirian because among all the
demigods we know there are only four or
five imperials depending on how you see
the glomide queen and they are queen
marika the glomide queen ronnie the
witch melania de severd and mikala the
unalloyd and just to get this out of
there we also know that strength or
power isn't necessarily the measure of
an imperium as we do know that general
radon was one if not the most powerful
demigod during the shattering yet he is
not an emperian
so yeah what makes an empyrean
there are a lot of ideas on what makes
an empirian but there are two ideas that
rise above all the others the first is
that an empirian is simply a demigod or
god chosen by two fingers and the second
is that imperials are special beings
born of a single god
we'll discuss both ideas but let's start
with the first one in that imperiums are
chosen by two fingers
this idea came from a conversation with
ronnie which goes
let us speak of the past a while
i was once an imperial
of the demigods
only i
mickeler and melania could claim that
title
each of us was chosen by our own two
fingers
as a candidate to succeed queen america
to become the new god of the coming age
which is when i received blithe
in the form of a vassal tailored for
imperial
but i would not acquiesce to the two
fingers
i stole the rune of death
slew mine own imperium flesh
casting it away
i would not be controlled by that thing
the two fingers and i have been cursing
each other ever since
and the baleful shadows
are their assassins
i turned my back on the two fingers
and we have each been cursing the other
since
the baleful shadows
are their assassins
as you saw the most important bit was
that ronnie mentioned that each of them
were chosen by their own two fingers
which is what made them imperiance this
is the main crux of the argument the one
thing confirmed in common with all the
imperials thus far is that they're all
chosen by a two fingers although we
don't really get to see mykola or
melania's two fingers unless you count
the dead two fingers on the divine
towers the two fingers are usually
associated with a greater will but
they're just agents of the greater will
itself so many interpret this as more of
being chosen by an outer god
this is further supported by the fact
that the gloam-eyed queen was chosen by
fingers as well not necessarily the two
fingers because the black flame ritual
simply says by the fingers
and thus is an empirian herself
but malacath defeated the glomeide
queens so it may be that the glomide
queen wasn't allied with the greater
will so the fingers of the gloam-eyed
queen might be allied to another god
another fact that supports this is that
marika is also an imperian and she was
also chosen by the two fingers of the
greater will now one of the assumptions
here is that an empirian is simply like
a status symbol given to a demigod or a
god by an outer god or in this case
specifically the greater will now the
counter argument for this actually made
a new theory about ronnie that is fairly
interesting but is rooted in a lot of
speculation
the theory goes that ronnie was born
from the amber egg that radagan gave
ranala i won't go into details of the
theory because i honestly don't know
much about it and i couldn't find the
original post or the video for this
theory but i've seen a lot of fragmented
comments about it so i just pieced them
all together but i believe the whole
basis of it is the secrets between
ratagan and ranala rani's imperial
status and the cutscene for the second
phase where ronnie spell emerges from
the amber egg but the theory basically
is trying to prove that ronnie is born
from a single god which is ratigan
whether this is true or not well that's
up to you if you do believe it though
then ronnie mikhail and melania are born
from a single god but there's nothing
proving america and the glomide queen
are born from a single god there are
also arguments that the two fingers are
basically the agents of the greater will
which means imperians were chosen by the
greater will
does this mean that imperians are beings
chosen by outer gods if that's the case
how about moog who was chosen by the
formless mother but didn't become an
empyrean and required mikala who was
already an empirian in order to ascend
to godhood his omen blood isn't really a
problem either because both melania and
michaela are also cursed yet they are
imperials now there are a lot more
arguments that people make but if i
cover them all then we'll be here
forever so instead let's move on to the
second theory
the second theory is that empirians are
born from a single god this idea
originally came from the remembrance of
the roth goddess item description which
states the following mikala and melania
are both children of a single god as
such they are both emperians but
suffered afflictions from birth
one was cursed with eternal childhood
and the other harbored wrought within
there have been arguments about the
grammar here to further push the fact
that being born from a single god is
needed but english isn't my first
language so i'll leave that for someone
else to cover in the comments down below
however an additional conversation in
the game that supports this idea was
from gowrie
queen america and her king consort
ranagan were blessed with twin demigods
and melania was one of them
she was born an imperial carrying the
scarlet rot
an empyrean
is no mere demigod
in the age of the elden ring and queen
maniker the precious empyrean was born
a new god to forge a new order
since millennia fought radon and the
great scarlet flower blossomed in aeonia
i have dedicated myself to her
and to the resplendence
of the order of rot
the cycle of decay
and rebirth
he mentions that melania was born as an
emperian meaning it's something that
they are born with rather than it just
being a status symbol of sorts he even
drives the idea that an emperian is no
mere demigod now despite gary saying the
twins were born from america and radigan
we know that in reality they are a
single god which supports the idea that
imperians are not just chosen but have
to be born as an emperian
now counterargument to this is that
there's nothing to prove that america
and the glomide queen are born from a
single god there is also the
conversation of queen america and
radigan which states
spoken echoes linger here
words of queen america
who vanished long ago
if you wish
i will share them with you
in america's own words
o radican
lil hound of the golden order
that yet to become me
thou art yet to become a god
let us be shattered
both
mine other self
meaning radigan may not have been a true
god yet when melania and michelle were
born but this is also nullified by the
fact that ranala and radigan's children
were demigods and we know for a fact
that ranala is not a god so ratagan must
have been
another argument is to debunk the
earlier theory that ronnie is born from
the amber egg and instead is a true
daughter of ranala and ratagan meaning
ronnie is not born from a single god but
is still an emperian
but that's about it it goes deeper than
this but i think this is a good stopping
point before we get to like very crazy
ideas already now as i said earlier
there are a lot more conversations and
arguments for both sides but in my
opinion these are the ones that people
argue the most over whether what is real
or not but now that you have the ideas
from both sides you can probably make
your own assumptions or just go with my
own personal opinion that it's just both
in parents are born a special kind of
demigod and are chosen by an outer god
in any case what do you guys think are
imperiants born or chosen or both let me
know in the comments down below and
please make any discussions down there
civil or at least try to be civil
please